Це унікальна ініціатива. До цих пір
молодіжних симфонічних оркестрів в Україні не було
Існували кілька проектів
як-от оркестр, до якого входять
музиканти з СНД.
Але от такого суто українського оркестру,
в якому б були молоді люди
з різних регіонів України,
ще не існувало, і мені здається,
що це для них є чимось новим
В першу чергу, ще тому, що
на жаль, в Україні до сих пір
грати в оркестрі не вважалось чимось престижним.
Рахувалося престижним – бути солістом.
Оркестр – це ніби щось другорядне.
І те, що зараз вони можуть відчути
оцю справжню енергію
колективного музикування,
енергію, коли всі з‘їжджаються, збираються,
кожен готується,
а потім усі спільно видають результат.
Вже зараз і навіть смішні моменти,
коли наприклад німецькі музиканти приходять і кажуть,
ви может поговорити з моїм колегою трубачем,
він не до кінця знає, як грати, наприклад, Моцарта.
Але я думаю, що наші тоді, напевно
скажуть, як треба грати Лятошинського.
Це дуже цікавий обмін!
Тому що, звичайно, менталітет німецький
і менталітет слов‘янський, вони свого роду є,
можливо, навіть протилежними, але можливо
це саме зараз буде дуже добрим доповненням,
що наші зможуть навчитись якоїсь такої
точності і зосередженості й підходу
від німецьких колег,
а можливо нашим німецьким гостям
буде цікаво поспілкуватися
з більш емоційними українцями.
Нове покоління вже зовсім інше,
ніж люди були раніше.
Навіть зараз дякуючи соціальним мережам,
люди знайомляться набагато швидше
і швидко вступають у контакт.
Ми набагато швидше можемо створити між нами містки.
Тому я думаю, що вони є надзвичайно відкритими
один до одного, і вже навіть зараз відчувається,
що це не дві різні групи людей,
а вони стають такою одною групою,
у якій усі переживають один за одного. І навіть, якщо
вони і роблять один одному зауваження, то це вони роблять заради
загальної справи, а не заради того, щоб показати,
що хтось є кращий, а хтось – гірший.
Думаю, що загалом буде великий дуже успіх проекту.
Мені здається, що останні роки кризи настільки
загасили в людях іскру в душі,
дуже багато з них
зациклились на матеріальних та соціальних проблемах.
Люди зараз бачать телебачення, їздять за кордон,
їм постійно здається, що вони чимось обділені,
що в Україні все погано, що в Україні ніколи-ніколи
не буде краще.
І саме цей проект, саме ця увага Європи
є доказом для людей того,
що насправді Європа відкриває свої двері для України
і Європа цікавиться Україною,
і саме це дає ту позитивну іскру,
той заряд і надію,
які людям необхідні саме для того,
щоб якось так встати з колін
і зробити певні кроки до виходу з кризи.